I am officially in my happy place right
now
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to this new
vlog series you'll be hearing from me
throughout this video in bits and bobs
as I try to piece together a month but
to begin with I'm going to take you back
to the start of the month when I was in
France I'm currently on holiday with
some friends from school in France this
is the cognac region basically a friend
of mine his parents owned this place as
a holiday home and they let it out to
people during the week to make money and
we've borrowed it for two weeks so we
did this a couple of years ago and it's
basically a really good way of those of
us who were really close in school he
went on to do different things in life
went off to different universities to
stay in touch so the start of this month
I'm here for two weeks which is I mean
there are worse places to be
this has felt like a kind of
inauspicious start to a new vlogging
series because I've done very little
vlogging basically the entire holiday
has been spent around this pool either
reading well I brought back six books
which wasn't the smartest move we've
also done a campaign of Dungeons &
Dragons which is the first time I've
ever played and the first time I've the
end which has been really fun experience
if one of our one of the party is
basically just an idiot Noble which has
been reading reading hutton we've gone
on a few trips to French towns and we've
booked in to have a con yak tour so
we're in the con yet region of France
but to be honest a lot this holidays
been a whole lot or nothing
France mate what are you doing when it
comes to parking this is shameful what
is this what is that that's even a
disabled spot apparently that person's
disability is being unable to park yeah
but I can part of better than these
people
I don't even drive anyway we're in
Cognac is in the actual town of cognac
because we're going to have a look at
some Kanye the drink
we just did the tasting experience at
Hennessy which is one of the main
producers shout out to them to stand out
stutters other than the cognac which is
really really nice
in the session first of all there's a
mother and baby here baby didn't know
anything to go just walk past me who had
finished both of his comments before
that even said you could drink of Buddha
sounds like we were made to be sniffing
and like yep okay I'd gets it written
well that kind of thing now you're just
like okay maybe they'll have something a
bit more full
Oh eventually however the holiday had to
come to an end and I had to come back I
was very happy to do so and so I started
vlogging on the very first day I was
back in the office today is the first
day back in the office I've been in the
UK for like two days now and I've had a
chance to set up a new office
configuration and so just Jen then you
get back into the swing of things but
today is the first day where I've hit
the ground running so this is my setup I
have a two screen setup and for those of
you who know the vlog series very well
but desk used to be here I moved it to
here so I wasn't being blinded by the
window at all times
I have been hard at work on something
that has hopefully been out for a really
long time by now the yogscast the
mythical flying beast video it's been an
absolute blast to work on this video
it's just taking a long time because
well trying to liaise with your cast and
work out when to do interviews for them
is difficult also getting interviews
with two scientists Alex and Ed's took
time and then you know I had to do my
PhD Corrections and there were a bunch
of reasons but basically it's been a
really fun project and hopefully the
videos done very well because I think it
deserves to I think it's a really
interesting video and I think it might
be the best piece of work like fun
in case you're wondering by the way this
was a triptych that I made during my PhD
I kind of want to get this framed at
some point which is basically a PhD in
three panels going from frustration to
boredom to finally being done this room
is very much a work in progress
basically I want to be able to do two
camera pieces four videos about here and
construct a set behind me so I've
already got the silver play button I've
got I've had this for ages this is a
bunch of hanger fish that Hank fish fish
Bank green drift me as part of the
project for awesome it was a prize like
one there we go Wiki car sticker we got
the original to do calculate basically I
want this to be like a set and when I do
streaming which hopefully has become a
regular thing already details on the
screen you're gonna see this corner then
you're also gonna see this wall which
I've also sort of partly designed this
was a article that I did for a magazine
a reviewers for couples
my friend John drew me a dick but and
then that leaves this wall for me to
have stuff that I can plan on and I
don't have to worry about it being on
camera as long as I'm careful when I'm
vlogging like this I have sort of my
goals for the year over there which I'm
going to show you in case I don't
achieve them and then I've got this
board of stuff which is probably blurred
because I probably can't show you all of
it but there we go we're back in
business basically I am so happy about
that I am so so happy to be back away I
love doing this so yeah it's gonna be a
busy week
[Music]
okay so in London I'm not someone phone
mode because guess there's Lydia for God
spoke Arden is camera found the reason
I'm in London it
hang on actually don't aware of going so
the reason I'm in London is because I've
been invited to an event by the BBC
that's where I'm going right now
this is broadcasting house as seen on TV
club I see making TV I've never been
here before
I'm really quite excited so this is
where mr. BBC lives
I'm here in the radio theater
broadcasting house for the launch of
cast well that was a fascinating
experience up there on stage is still
Stephen Fry who you might know from I
don't know being Stephen Fry but also
this our auditorium is amazing this is
the BBC radio auditorium so this is for
a radio for production as you can see in
the formula but I'm behind me for
example it's very interesting from my
point view so to the content greater to
see how the studio is miked but me
there's a bunch of what like where are
they they're cardioid Mike's like em
pipes or something not dissimilar for
Heidi's mother and I was able to ask
some questions unfortunately unfortunat
wasn't filming at the time about the
medium and he was marveling and compared
to other forms like books or movies how
easy broadcasting is the fact that BBC
literally gave him something to plug
into his iPhone and you get studio
quality recordings and you can make it a
cusper ad or full of them using that
material is really quite inspirational
it goes to show but podcasting is
probably most India for formats those
mean that there is such a low entry so
Barry attend anyone can do and look
things all the people here with
podcasters so apparently many people
watch the show itself the ratline I've
got to say it sounds really interesting
we nobody I've brought here to say nice
things about it because I'm an
influencer but genuinely I'm gonna go
home and download the I think they said
there were two episodes available
because it sounds like a really really
interesting story and I just had a
spoiler in that networking meeting yeah
I will leave a link in the description
to this because genuinely sounds pretty
good and I will probably I'll probably
tweeting a review by the time this comes
out I will have tweeted a review of the
sites that are out but yeah genuinely
really excited to have a listen now
however because I'm in London it is
allowed as
I'm sorry but it is quite pretty look I
wasn't done with London for the month
there yet if I was to give it a review
with the ratline now having listened to
all the episodes that are available up
to date it's very good as you'd expect
you know from radio for producing it the
production value is fantastic the series
just feels very professional my gripe
with it is that it I know what's coming
I know what's interesting about it I
feel like if I didn't know that are you
would have stopped listening after about
the first episode maybe the second one
because I felt like it's slow moving
which is fine in itself but it doesn't
tease about what's coming up people need
to have their attention for podcasts
continually updated and I feel like the
show doesn't do that but if you stick
with it it's a phenomenally interesting
story and I'm really interested to get
to the bottom of it and then the last
few episodes so I'll leave a link in the
description actually if you wanna check
it out it is it is good yeah yeah
[Music]
so this week has been spent largely
editing this video which is the flying
mythical beast video it has without a
doubt been the most intensive video to
animate in the almost half probably the
runtime is in after-effects so
animations like doing the data points
appearing on a graph that's doing every
one of those by hand it's actually quite
quick once you get into the swing of
things but this week is based keeping a
lot of really fiddly tiny bits of
editing I mean this project is probably
most ambitious video I've ever tried to
make there's four interviews in it
there's a whole buttload of animations
as some original research which I
whatever me really call it research
looking and scientific literature
extrapolating it to fantasy which was
done for the video you know a long
process of writing and rewriting based
on the interviews that I had to put the
two scientists and then there was the
oxcart stuff that was the largest delay
it was actually just getting a time when
we could record because they're so busy
but you know and then there was a big
old chunk in the middle you know thesis
got in the way but this project is
basically taking about six months from
inception to completion the other thing
about today is I'm being allowed out of
the house and Hicksville is driving me
to the station Thank You pixel girl I'm
off to London
so the reason I'm leaving the house and
actually being around
it's because I'm part of a network of
youtubers this is something that is
probably means very very few people in
fact when I talk to the Yogscast about
this network even they didn't know it
existed
basically there's a network called
standard which is got people like me in
it it's got people of engineering when
their productions CGP grey hello
Internet
all these educators who make educational
content basically and this network has
improved my videos immensely you know
not just in terms of the resources we
get access to like music but also the
feedback we get from other creators who
were part of the same basically one of
the great strengths of being in this
network is the people who also in the
network the people here is parts network
from lessons from screenplay and he just
happens to be visiting London and so I'm
just popped into town to
so having Matt up at the VNA I decided
to take Michael to the Natural History
Museum because he handed him before I
left - Louis he lost dinosaurs so the
short stories were in the dinosaur
section address - so you made it through
dinosaurs Michael message in the
screenplay is here how are you enjoying
them it's amazing
it helps to stand in front of a blue
whale let me clear this very moment it's
huge like surprisingly huge when you see
it in place yep
so Michael your channel is lessons from
the screenplay how did that how did it
start what why did you start making
YouTube videos it was I've been doing a
lot of editing gigs that were really
soulless and not fun she stalks choo
choo okay how can I get back to doing
something that's like fun but maybe
productive and so the channels like a
way for me to learn screen writing well
also like deep things dramatic it's cool
I mean and I'm not just saying this
picture here it's definitely one of my
favorite channels so so check it out
there'll be a link down there and well
we're going to enjoy the rest of the
address to museum but currently
wandering towards the giant which blew
my mind as a kid that's so cool I am
officially in my happy place right now
[Music]
okay very busy day but very interesting
day today I just got back from the gym
it is like 9:00 in the morning and I
need so it's about 9:00 in the morning I
just got back from the gym and later on
today I am traveling to Windsor give a
talk at a school now I haven't written
this talk well that's not fair I've
written bullet points for this talk but
basically I need to take some points
from this which is a beautiful textbook
nonlinear dynamics and chaos by Steven
Strogatz was one of the course books in
my favorite module at Oxford and I
basically bought the secondhand one off
of Amazon because partly I wanted to
just own the textbook but also it has a
specific section I wanted to give a talk
about and it was an excuse to buy the
book I want to give this talk on chaos
Connor as a challenge to myself to see
if I can but also because it's really
interesting because there's a bit of
maths that I remember doing from a
degree which is known as the Leah poon
of exponent which sort of it describes
how quickly trajectories divergent phase
space in other words how chaotic a
system is I want to see if I can take
this textbook sort of work on it and
just couple of equations and make that
into a convincing and engaging talk
we'll see
so the talk basically took all day to
write it was a bigger job than I thought
it would be so I'm not gonna get chance
doing editing which sucks but there's
there's always touring what's
interesting about this talk there isn't
what I'm talking about it's where I'm
going
time to head to London again I've now
punched through London and I'm in Slough
which is about as beautiful as it sounds
I'm only in Slough to get to where I
need to go
for those of you who don't know Ethan is
one of the most famous if not the most
famous school in the UK it is
notoriously old it was founded by Henry
the sixth and it is notoriously
expensive it costs over ten thousand
pounds a term to send your child there
so unless you're on a scholarship it's
well over thirty thousand pounds a year
to send your kid to Eton and so when I
was invited to give a talk there I was
hesitant to say yes geez that's the
school and a half isn't it my
instructions here sound like something
from Harry Potter I am meeting somebody
by the burning bush by the circular
library no wonder these kids feel at
home at Oxbridge you could be forgiven
for thinking this as a College soundly
different from high school okay so it's
a library but it's not circular its
octagonal but I think that's that's
probably okay
there are kids walking around in gowns
and suits and wipeouts
I'm in a suit and I feel underdressed so
this is the small humble abode where I'm
giving a talk tonight oh wow
gosh it's certainly something okay so
talk given I was a professional and I
completely forgot to tell my camera on
so what you're seeing is footage from
the QA I would like to put so basically
because it's a school I didn't want to
film people because I do parental
admission but someone who I think can
give his own information this is Harry
who invited me to give the talk so what
is your exact title it's not less the
Society one of the secretaries of the
scientific society so you've invited me
to give a talk as part of a series of
talks now who is he who's having a talk
next week
whoa in a couple of weeks Nobel Prize
winner ham from 2016 did you tell me
this just before I came on stage I may
have I think that went fine but that
seemed that as people seem to get on
board thing you know yeah no I certainly
understand chaos soon so much better
than I did before so that's what I
wanted to hear amazing I still can't get
over this bloody building what I was
invited to give a talk or eat and I was
hesitant to accept because Eaton has
become associated with basically the
antithesis of what I have been trying to
do on YouTube
it's became associated with a social
stratification in the UK you know to
come here is ten thousand pound more
than 10,000 pounds of term if you're not
on scholarship it's a school that kind
of represents to most people sort of the
epitome of elitism in UK you get rich
people sending their kids here those
kids then get almost certainly fantastic
education and then those kids get into
Oxbridge and that's basically exactly
the opposite of what I have been trying
to accomplish with my Oxbridge access
content so for me to come here and to
give a talk about science and try
inspire people they prevent it did
present me with some a kind of moral
conundrum should I come here and give
more advantages to kids who have plenty
of advantages ready or will my time be
better spent
going to another school I mean the fact
of the matter is that I wasn't invited
to another school so it was choosing
between doing this or working on other
videos and to be honest maybe took my
time would have been better spent making
other videos but at the same time
accepting this and coming here helped me
become a better public speaker it
allowed me to write a new talk and you
know what I think was actually quite a
good talk on chaos but there's something
more important than that because my work
on YouTube to do with access has been
all about trying to undo ignorance and
preconceptions and misconceptions that
people for backgrounds like me had about
Oxbridge and this is why education is
such an important force because the most
dangerous thing in the world is
ignorance and not understanding how
another person thinks or not having
access to certain information that's
what I've been trying to do in this
channel all along but the fact of the
matter is I have always been ignorant
about how schools other than state
comprehensives are operated because I
didn't go to one and eat public schools
like Eton we're a complete enigma to me
I am you know no idea and more
importantly no interest in learning
about what life was like you what the
kids were like you so integrating to
give a talk here not only was I able to
improve my public speaking and yadi yadi
Anna more importantly than that it
allowed me to get a different
perspective to see what it is like for
kids in this kind of situation because
you can't the crush the kids you can
have a go a child being born into a
certain set of circumstances coming here
has allowed me to understand how this
place is so successful at sending people
to Oxbridge they're sending people to
successful paths in life and I think
coming here has made me a better
advocate for access I think it has
allowed me to understand from both sides
of the fence now how the system works
how people perceive particularly
Oxbridge admissions and you know more
broadly than that where you're gonna end
up in the world I don't want to go into
details us too exactly what it is I
learned but suffice to say that it's to
do with the possibilities that are
presented to you what is presented as
being achievable what is presented as
even normal
and it's a reaffirmed to me which I
suspected it would its reaffirmed why
doing access and why presenting the
image of going to a state school going
to works for it doing a PhD why that's
important to portray I know that some
people will have a go at me for coming
here and yes I won't like the prestige
of giving a talk here and being able to
visit these amazing buildings was part
of it I'm sure some people will have a
go at me for that but I think that
coming here has made me a better has
given me a better understanding and so
made me a better advocate for access so
I stand by my decision to come here and
thank you
Perry and everybody who came to the talk
here you were a genuinely loved the
audience thank you for inviting me I
enjoyed my time here it was it was
certainly eye-opening okay so to lighten
the mood here is a clip that resulted
from pixel girl by girl friends working
out how to turn my camera on at long
last
[Music]
oh no the pixel girl is just worked out
my camera works
hang on what's wrong with your foot
pixel go I don't wanna talk about it see
you soon
well last night because I went to ahem
I'm going up as well pixel pixel go I
went to netball and she tripped pixel
girl tripped over her own feet and has
sprained her ankle so today when she was
teaching what happened you had to be
wheel out on an evacuation chair in
front of the kids like a [ __ ] and
then go to hospital she limped across
the threshold of the house because she
wasn't able to walk I have every
sympathy I really do but it's kind of
funny
Thanks sorry I got boyfriend points
because we had emergency village areas
that I hadn't told her about for just
such a case as this say can't see over
my thumb is but yeah boyfriend one sec
hey that fellow your camera hey Dad
that's not a photo you just attracting
back oh no you're too tall
fade out fade out fade out no you need
to stay where you are
[Music]
all right quick test shots see okay so
the mythical flying beast video is out
it has done pretty terribly on release
but I'm actually not terribly surprised
first video in a while
the algorithm favors channels that
upload regularly and it's also a long
video now one hoping is because this is
also what happened when I released the
Star Wars video about which planets
could really exist which I'll leave a
link in the description having it's
another one of my best videos that was a
very slow boat that was a very
disappointing release but it's gone on
to be one of the really big hits the
channel it's consistently now one of the
top videos in my in terms of generating
watch time so I'm hoping that this video
is gonna be the same it's gonna be a bit
as a slate burner it will generate a lot
of watch time that will then boost it
onto a algorithm and it'll be a positive
feedback cycle it will get recommended
and then it generates more watch time
because it's such a long video and I
think it keeps videos attention people's
attention it's got about a nine minute
on average a few times so that's pretty
good
so yeah disappointing but not surprised
I just recorded the blog talking about
where I've been
which is why the camera is set up on a
tripod might have a nice lens on it and
why I have premiere open on this screen
because I've just finished through it
the rough cut of it I am going to spend
another half an hour or so tweaking it
getting some music in there and that's
half ready to go before I do sort of
another editing session tomorrow but
today's today is gonna be a very good
day come with me
because
because I am in the dead center of
London for a really exciting evening in
another London first to me this month I
am at the Barbican Centre and I'm here
to watch a concert but not just any
concert so the Barbican is an Art Centre
in London and according to Wikipedia I
definitely didn't just look this up just
before he came here
it's the largest cultural center in
Europe tonight I'm here for music but
also science
I haven't even gone into the performance
yet this is amazing
so the story with this is a couple of
days ago I got an email from the BBC
asking me would I be interested in
coming to a concert the plan is by calls
because today is exactly a hundred years
since the piece was from yet so if you
don't know the planet is a suite by
Christophe host who is an English
composer doesn't sound like it but it is
written about the astrological
characters of the classical Greek
planners they said would you be
interested because we know what you're
interested in to the blog and the cure
things about me and I do music and
there's an announcement however that was
something even more interesting than
just the music which has been my
favourite pieces as the person who's
introducing it and talking about the
science of planets during their just up
for me to press tickets and
unfortunately Pixlr fellows way this
weekend visiting our family so she can
come on a kid I loved it so a friend of
mine has bravely step forwards to bear
this unfortunate set of events
it's my friend David who's very sweaty
he his train was late and he had to run
here the last time people saw you I was
falling off a waterfall in a hole
many many times
you were also done with a PhD yes and I
few months before Simon did and beam
work
industries doing data analysis what was
it like in industry and
more regimented but less a key
difference so because it's a classical
concert and I'm not trash and David's
definitely not trying to stuck out of
frame I won't be filming during because
I don't want to steal Aaron's property
but also it's gonna be this might be put
on the BBC because there is if there's a
camera literally pointing directly at us
they've already identified the people
they want in the broadcast probably
behind us I'm gonna be filming it I'll
see you after what should be an amazing
first half so we're not still an
interval David is just securing nibbles
for us thank you David
we've also nice troops reception so the
first half was fantastic the call I mean
what do you think of the quality of the
music David is a musician much more than
I ever was
really good really good we were talking
just now and our gripes with the
performance is armed with music there
are aspects to it where basically
they've been projecting images the
pilots in question behind which is a
fine idea I could have done a better
video presentation which isn't
necessarily a fair comparison also Brian
Cox he's been fantastic
he also so basically before each piece
he's been giving a talk about
understanding of the panelists hope you
got very excited of penis because David
is volcanologist
yes we were actually just having a chat
Bob and I was like oh yeah I should
probably book he gave me till just
before Jupiter which there was just sort
of spontaneous bulls which was really
nice it was sort of linking
well I have to do this again cut to me
in the future talking about this in more
detail because my arms getting tired
it's too complicated we need a line the
point that Brian Cox made was that the
central theme of you Peter is known as
the facts that tune or the I vow to be
my country tune and it's become
associated with patriotism nationalism
and conservative leanings and sort of
turning inwards and what we actually got
to Jupiter we took a very famous picture
called the pale blue dot image the Carl
Sagan wrote this wonderful prose about
how science can accomplish amazing
things when we do the exact opposite of
what conservativism wants us to do when
we rise above the divisions of
nationalities and who speaks what
language or who comes from where science
is this amazing force in a social world
and that was a really powerful message
to me and it was theater broke out and
spontaneous applause by the way you can
hear the whole concert sperm if you're
in the UK on BBC iPlayer they'll be a
link in the description so you can hear
set speech and set applause and I think
possibly had such an effect on me
because I spent the month being aware of
the divisions in society and being aware
of other people's perspectives but also
welcoming friends who had never met
before from faraway places and finding
that we had so much in common and I
don't know it was a really really lovely
way to round out the month and thank you
the BBC incidentally thank you very much
for inviting me because I had a
fantastic time I'd love to do more stuff
like that in the future that was it for
this month let me know what you thought
of the new format in the comments or
perhaps if there are any more Lego kits
that I should be buying because I had
way too much fun building mouthing thank
you very much for watching do leave a
like if you enjoyed the video do comment
with what you thought and I'll see you
in the next one
[Music]